let's explore what happens to
determinants when you multiply them by a
scalar so let's say we wanted to find
the determinant of this matrix of a b c
d by definition the determinant here is
going to be equal to a times D minus B
times C or C times B either way ad minus
BC that's the determinant right there
now what if we were to multiply one of
these rows by a scaler let's say we
multiply it by K so we have the
situation a B let's multiply the second
row times K so we have K C and K D now
what it's what's the determinant going
to look like we're going to have a times
K D or just write that as K ad minus K C
times B or we could write that as K BC
if we factor out the K we get that
equals K times ad minus BC now you
immediately see that this thing is the
same thing as this thing so this is
equal to K times the determinant of a b
c d so when you just multiply a row by a
scaler just one row not the entire
matrix when you just multiply a row by
tum by some scalar the resulting
determinant will be the original
determinant times that scalar now you
might say well what happens if I
multiply if I multiply the whole matrix
times that scalar well that's equivalent
to multiplying by a scalar twice right
if I say that let's say I have the
matrix a and the matrix a is equal to a
b c d if i were to think about the
matrix K a now I'm not just multiplying
one row I'm multiplying the whole matrix
by a scalar this is going to be equal to
K lowercase a KB K C and K D and when
you figure out its determinant the
determinant the determinant of K times a
is going to be equal to the determinant
of K a KB KC
kay C and KD and here you're immediately
going to see her to end up with K
squared terms you're gonna have K
squared times ad it's going to be equal
to K squared ad minus K squared B C or K
squared times ad minus BC or K squared
times the determinant of just of just a
so you have to be very careful and this
is only for a two by two case you'll
find out if this was an N by n matrix
that this would have been K to the N so
the takeaway is the only way you can say
that it's going to be a some scalar
multiple times your original determinant
is only if you multiply one row one row
times that scalar multiple not the whole
matrix let's see how this extends to
let's extend it to maybe a three by
three case let's take it do it and you
know you might say hey Sal you just pick
the second row does it work with the
first row I'll leave I'll leave that for
you to determine but it does it does
work it doesn't matter which row I
multiplied it by let's take the three by
three case let's say we have some matrix
let's call this a again I'm redefining a
going to be a b c d e f g h i and then
if you take its determinant let's just
take its determinant the determinant of
a is going to be equal to well we could
do it a couple of different ways but
i'll just pick some arbitrary row
because that's the row that we're going
to multiply by some scalar so let's just
take that role right there
so determinant of a is going to be equal
to remember the plus/minus pattern right
remember plus minus plus minus plus
minus plus minus plus that little
checkerboard pattern so d is a minus
right there so it's going to be equal to
minus D times the determinant of its
sub-matrix so you cross out that column
and that roads B CH i b c h i and it's
going to be plus e times its sub-matrix
a/c g i a/c g i and it's going to be
minus F times you get rid of that row
that
de gh the determinant of de gh that's
the determinant of this matrix a now
what if we define some new matrix here
let's call it a prime let me may scroll
down a little bit let me define a prime
right here a prime I'm just going to
multiply this row by a scalar so it's
going to be equal to a b c KD ke + KF
I'm not multiplying the whole matrix
times the scalar I can't say this is ka
I'm just multiplying one of its rows and
then I have G H and I so what's the
determinant of a prime going to be the
determinant of a prime and I put that
Prime data so it's different than a or
maybe it's you know but it's derived
from a I just multiplied one row of a
times a scalar well I can go along that
same row that I did up here I go along
that same row and the only difference is
is that instead of having a d I now have
a KD instead of an e I now have a ke so
instead of a d I'm gonna have a KD there
instead of an e I'm gonna have a ke
there so I can it's going to be this
exact same thing but I can replace this
guy this guy in this guy with them
multiplied by K so it's going to be
equal to minus KD times the determinant
of the sub-matrix BCH I I'm not even
going to look over here it's going to be
the same thing as that one up there plus
ke times the determinant of AC GI plus
minus minus KF times the determinant of
de gh and what is this equal to this is
equal to if you just factor out the K
it's equal to K times this so it's equal
to K times the determinant of a so our
result also worked for three by three
case I just happen to pick the middle
row but I encourage you to pick other
rows and to see what happens and so
let's actually do it for the general
case because I've just been giving you
particular examples and I like to show
you the general proof when the general
proof isn't too hairy so let's say I
have an N by n matrix so let's say that
I have a matrix a let's say that a is n
by n
so it equals you can write it like this
this is the first row first column a 1 1
a 1 2 all the way to a 1n I'm going to
pick some arbitrary row here that I'm
going to end up multiplying by a scalar
so you know we could go down here let's
say row a I this is a I won a I 2 all
the way to a I n this is some row that
I'm going to use to determine the
determinant remember we can go down any
row to get the determinant then finally
you keep going you get a an1 an2 all the
way to a NN this says this is as general
as you can get for an N by n matrix now
let's figure out its determinant so the
determinant of a now I'm just going to
go down this row right there that row
right there so the determinant of a the
determinant of a is equal to what it's
equal to well we have to remember the
checkerboard pattern and we don't know
where we are in the checkerboard pattern
because I just picked an arbitrary
general row here but we can use the
general formula that the sign is going
to be determined by negative 1 to the I
I don't know if I is even or odd so it's
going to be I plus 4 this term 1 power
that's its sign this is what gives us
the checkerboard pattern let me make
that clear it looks complicated but this
is just a checkerboard checkerboard
checkerboard pattern that's that's just
that right there times this term right
there
so times a I so the coefficient a a I 1
and then times this guy's sub matrix and
you remember the sub matrix you get rid
of this row and this column is going to
be everything that's left over so times
that sub matrix is of AI 1 AI 1 and then
you're going to keep and there's going
to be plus let me just keep doing it
plus negative 1 to the I plus 2 times a
I to times its sub-matrix I 2 all the
way
you just keep going plus minus one to
the I plus n times AI you're in the nth
column and then its sub-matrix this is
going to be an N minus 1 by n minus 1
matrix all of these are going to be I n
just like that that's the determinant of
a and we can actually rewrite it in
Sigma notation that'll simplify things a
little bit so the determinant of a we
can rewrite it as the sum the sum from J
is equal to 1 to J I'll write it
explicitly here J is equal to n of of
negative 1 to the I plus J times a I J
and then each of the sub matrices a I J
this thing right here this thing right
here is just another way it's just
another way of writing this thing I
wrote up there where you know I'm just
saying the sum you just take J equal 1
put them in there you get this term
right there you take J equal 2 you add
it you get this term right there you
keep doing it you get J equal and you
get that term right there so these are
these two things are equivalent so what
happens what happens if I have some new
matrix let's say let me copy and paste
my current matrix so let me copy and
paste it actually let me copy and paste
everything let me copy and paste
everything that'll make things move
quickly I copied it and now let me paste
it just like that let me define a new
matrix let me define my new matrix a
prime it's still an N by n matrix but
that row that I just happen to use to
determine my determinant I'm going to
multiply it by a scalar K so it's K AI k
k a 1 k AI 2 k AI n just like that so
what's the determinant of a prime well
we're just going to go down this row
again but now instead of just an AI 1 we
have a kai1 instead of an AI 2 we have a
kai2 instead of a K AI and we have a K
AI n so it's determinant is just going
to be this same thing but we're gonna
have
instead of an AI J everywhere we're
gonna have a que AI J so this is going
to be since the determinant of a prime
and so this is equal to this is equal to
we could just take out this this
constant right here it has no eyes or
J's in it so we can just has no J's in
it in particular so we can just take it
out so it's equal to K times the sum
from J is equal to 1 to J is equal to n
of minus 1 to the I plus J times a IJ a
and this is the coefficient and then
this is the sub matrix for each of those
coefficients a IJ that's a matrix right
there an n minus 1 by n minus 1 matrix
and then you know you immediately
recognize I think you saw where this was
going
this right here is just the determinant
of a so the determinant so we get the
result that the determinant of a prime
is equal to K times the determinant of a
times the determinant of a so we've just
shown you in general you have any N by n
matrix if you multiply only one row not
the whole matrix only one row by some
scalar multiple K it's the resulting
determinant will be your original
determinant times K now as I touched on
this in the original video what happens
if you keep what if you multiply what is
the determinant what is the determinant
of K times a so now we're multiplying
every row times K or another way to
think about is you're multiplying now I
guess you're multiplying n rows times K
right so you're doing this n times so if
you multiply K times itself n times will
you get you get K to the N so this is
going to be equal to K to the N times
the determinant of a right if you just
do it once you get K times the
determinant of a now if you do a 2nd row
you're going to get K times K times the
determinant of a you do a third row you
can get K to the third time's the
determinant of a the fourth row K to the
four times the determinant of a if you
do them all all n rows you're gonna have
K to the N times the determinant of a
anyway hopefully you found that
interesting and I encourage you to
experiment with this other
try-try going down a column and seeing
what happens